is there an interesting definable
distinction between liberal and
Progressive team that's a maybe one of
the most interesting ones 10 years ago
liberal often meant what now we mean by
Progressive
more recently the progressive socialist
leaning part of the political Spectrum
has started to use liberal to Mean Joe
Biden to mean someone who is not really
left enough so liberal is very
interesting because I remember talking
with my audience years ago maybe eight
years ago or something like that where I
identified I'm going to now use the term
Progressive more commonly to describe my
own beliefs because liberal has now been
made a smear it's being shifted into
something else and it also means more of
like a center-left politics so it's
changed in some sense by by necessity by
force and also because the the Spectrum
has shifted to some degree